I think first and foremost we have to
come to terms of the fact that because
we don't have a blood test and because
it's hard to see why someone may have a
psychiatric illness versus not having a
psychiatric illness we're not as
understanding about it so that if
someone is in a wheelchair or someone's
bleeding or someone's disfigured while
we might shun them We certainly have
some kind of sympathy for them yet when
you see a little kid who's bouncing all
over the supermarket and the mother
seems completely harried and can't seem
to be able to get control of her somehow
it must be her poor management skills
that is causing this child to do poorly
or something the child is eating or
something the child has experienced and
unfortunately the public is always very
very far behind the real science so for
instance you know Sigmund and Anna Freud
believed that almost all psychiatric
illness was caused by something your mom
and dad did whether they did it on
purpose or not didn't make a difference
but somehow there was a traumatic event
that changed the trajectory of your
lives and therefore you needed a
therapeutic experience that you could
get unconsciously with your
psychoanalyst and between you and it
could take a very long period of time
and those symptoms would disappear and
it didn't make a difference if the
symptoms were inattention hyperactivity
or whether it was sadness and
irritability or anxiety and worry so the
public still believes very much that
these are not as real and are
unfortunately they haven't grasped the
fact that we know they're know these are
no-fault brain disorders with very
strong genetic influences and how do we
know that the genetic and there's lots
of evidence so that if I have ADHD and I
have a twin brother who's identical
which means we share identical genetic
material there's a 99% chance that he
will have ADHD and if I have a fraternal
twin brother what did the channel
fraternal twin brother
sister we share the same amount of
genetic material as any set of siblings
and therefore if I have ADHD he has
about a 70% chance of having ADHD so
quite clearly there's a very strong
genetic component the other way we look
at is adoption studies so if I have ADHD
and I produce a child that is put up for
adoption that child will have the same
risk of having ADHD whether he grew up
my house or not
he will have nothing to do with the risk
that his adoptive father brings to the
table and his parenting style so we know
that genetic influences affect whether
or not you get these illnesses and by
those genetic influences will affect
brain structure and will affect brain
functioning and therefore put you at
risk for her psychiatric illness